ET là
Salut le matin quand tu ne fais que t'exposer bébé
brille comme
encore dans les vagues de la mer que seulement
reine
Le non-tissé de porcelaine peut être
si beau
règne de marques que seul ra voudrait pour
sinon, il n'est pas tissé d'être, il est possible d'être
si belle peau bronzée juste de
Copacabana
Je veux vivre cet amour cet amour
un bon veut quand même
jolie fille
étoile la séquence et c'est ici que brille le
South Star aussi précieux que nous
l'amour et Mateus est arrivé a un assaisonnement qui
tué
piquer le venir entre dans la roue à Marcos Ana
brisé la flamme de ce regard fait l'amour est
plus loin
notre samba brisée entre dans le cercle
Appelez ce regard aimer la paix est plus
près d'ici juste pour te voir sambar
Mon cher
tambourin
publier se fatiguer tu veux maintenant que
adieu
ET là
C'est
Allons-y, mon Dieu, maudit, y'a temp Street qui
tué
guéris, prends le volant, puis-je Sandra
brisé la flamme de cet œil paix amour et
la main existe
demander entrez notre
samba brisée la flamme de ce regard fait
l'amour est plus loin
près d'ici et juste pour te voir
samba mon bon
tambourin
public et marié voulant ta bouche parce que
les gens viennent
O
football à prendre à prendre A Timbalada j'ai marché
une demi-heure
et en route pour Dubaï Aruanda Rael do Roberto
aller travailler et
ET là